ok also die zweite samstag wieder so was
man tut ist liest du so einfach vor es
ist dunkel und honig das ist ekelhaft
meine sehr verehrten herren herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ist
guido frank heidmann serie die bei euch
auch sehr beliebt ist wo ich mit
verschiedenen beim ersten test dass sie
immer gehasst haben und ist dafür ja
verwirklicht wissen weiter nach wie vor
euch vorschläge für essens kombinationen
geben lassen von denen keiner denken
würde dass die lecker sind die aber
angeblich gut schmecken und lässt sich
heute zusammen mit meiner wunderbaren
co-moderatorin eine runde kein applaus
für könnte man fängt dieses jahres aber
wir erkennen ganz klar den augen es
handelt sich um einen anderen menschen
als heute werden einige kommen jetzt mit
einem start ohne witz also 90 prozent
von den habe ich noch nie überhaupt auch
nur im kopf dass man das kombinieren
kann aber ja einige dinge raus gehauen
ohne wird sich hunderte von nach
bekommen den vorschlägen zwar richtig
krass lange da höre dir haben die erste
kombination leute die haben schon aus
dem leben geschäft hat noch nie von so
was gehört und zwar schreibt julia
punkten älteste mal bitte nutella mit
chips gibt vorlauf zur sache die
eigentlich wo man denkt dass die immer
ekelhaft sind dann sind die folgen
zusammen hatte ausnahme jahres einen
veganen aber jetzt endlich unsere chips
leute natürlich ja es ist auch nicht das
video ja deswegen auch die teller ist so
ich habe zumindest versucht leute
das hat eine aktuelle kalorien aber das
meer ist okay
kriegst du das so ich glaube es kriegs
noch nicht raus zu keiner wollte mir
mein löffel reflex das kann man sich das
schiff sind richtig durchziehen oder
herzogstand ok chips mit nutella eure
essens kombinationen nummer eins erst
mal noch der held also muss muss ja
leute geht wie so was mich ärgert ist
damit ihr das schreiben
naja ich gerade richtig saß
53 vorteil aller welt
[Musik]
es wäre natürlich auch keine essen
testen wie die leute wenn ich im
hintergrund mindestens fünf menschen
sitzen will die einrichtung zusammen
man kennt ihn das funktioniert so mit
eine seriöse und videoüberwachten kunden
schmeckt ist es morgen 33 das ist
richtig geil wie im salzigen und dabei
aber extra salzige chips gaben keine
paprika chips nur weil ich bin auch
relativ froh dass du bist nicht wusste
dass es existiert weil das ist ungefähr
so dass ungesunde was man überhaupt
essen kann auf dem planeten
das ist noch vor sich einfach ein kilo
butter einfach rein zu pressen die
fresse alle drei sie auf die idee kommen
sollte jetzt große vorräte ein
hotelangestellter macht sich das blech
an den ball wurde durch das wasser zu
bleiben
kleine rote ausgepeitscht kannst du dein
schlimmstes sonst
bauer aber gesagt dass aus dem fall dass
den menschen lebenswichtig sind damit
sogar bei minus 31 mio angekommen glaubt
der punkt ist bereits über die zweite
satz ist okay heute samstag wieder so
was man tut ist liest du es einfach vor
es ist dunkel und honig sekunden sind am
start
bis am start ist ab heute waren schickte
wird die erste kurve sind glas honig
drauf
da konnte die glas du bist du diese
marke noch mal geld nicht alles ich esse
alles also die topleute die erste
kombination gut geschmeckt aber das hier
ist aber mal ganz artikelnummer ich fand
das gar nicht ohne witz ich finde es
auch beweisen diese gurke rainer dann
ist er noch so könig braucht also offen
gegenüber neuen sachen aber das hier
was bei der ganzen jetzt ziemlich gut
heute ist das so gefühlt 91 oder
vorschläge mit nutella waren das heißt
der nächste ist auch mit hotel ab und
zwar gut aber was kommt jetzt
fisch käse wurst man kennt sollte man
geht in den supermarkt greift sich aus
dem regal eine frische packungen käse
machen wir dazu fähig sie es kurz ins
gesicht
geile kombination mit nutella ist alles
klar also dass ich meine praktische
kombination leute wenn ihr persönlich
kinder habe wahrscheinlich kinder oder
so ja alle kinder okay
die kinder müssen in die schule dann
könnt ihr den einfach morgens um auf
jeden fall eine gesunde ernährung
gesichert ist wahrscheinlich das ist
übertrieben gurke mit honig dass sie
klar dass
über sich gemacht weil ich eh nicht zu
krass da musst du diese ganze scheibe
einfach so kleine geräusch das perfekt
ist heute optimal kämpfen aus erkennbar
die nutella ist oder ein perfekter
anwalt das mit heller haut heißt das ist
manchmal eine abstimmung die die nutella
leute die nutella lasst uns keinen krieg
anfangen aber die natürlich könnt ihr
auch nicht kommentar stand ich glaube
nicht dass der chef das geschichte vom
bistro bier probiert das ist wirklich
lecker und es kommt jemand aus einem
stillen publikum ferne probieren es
gerne da gar kein käse nur noch schöner
ist es richtig geld was du bisher noch
so eine idee von zum herzhaften käse
drin zu ich habe jetzt auch schon
scheiße von den nährwerten her also von
der gesundheit haben einen teller drin
ist aber mit käse ein bisschen besser
als mit chips studien aber ein bisschen
auch topic ich habe gerade so hier ins
fenster geschaut firma grenze da sieht
man mich und dann hatte ich so ganz kurz
moment so okay ich habe auch nie gesagt
dass ich immer mit einem baguette käse
mit dem teller wissen
egal ob youtube sei alles möglich war
der nächste kombination da wirst du
vermutlich raus sein die nächste
kombination ist leberwurst mit apfel
gibt er diese leberwurst mit apfel drin
erst die ganze drücken weil der mühle in
gedanken das feuer holen war es gibt
vegane leberwurst mit apfelessig drittel
ich sag's euch also ich habe heute ist
muss dazu sagen ich heute supermarkt und
hab tatsächlich auch selbst leberwurst
mit apfel fertig gemixt schon gesehen
dabei schon mal komplett raus aber dass
das ganze an der hand gibt ist eine
krankheit die drauf kommen mit
leberwurst und ab und zu testen aber wir
haben natürlich nach drei jahren
kommentar über übrigen lebensmittel dem
apfel geht es noch gut okay so natürlich
noch ist live den erfolg denn die
youtube schon raus aus dem appell der
fall ist
die chips dewitt alles klar
ich habe immer alles besser für die
leber probiert so auch heute zu essen
okay was ich habe mir eines leistung
heraus geschnitten mit pak einfach mal
gute alte hausmannskost haben wir ein
bisschen leberwurst und
es ist leider abgehalten es ist
natürlich geil also was ihr nicht nur
von der honig logo aber das ist auch es
ist auch seltsam so weil ich weiß nicht
so leberwurst auf dem apfel aber es ist
schritt ich muss leider zugeben und du
kannst dich probieren
du kannst dich kurz und leute jetzt zum
ende noch mal eine kombination ich sagte
mir das erste es ist noch mal ein hotel
aber um mitkommt erzählt nein das ist so
einfach in einer sehr sehr vielseitig
ist ihr damit kann man nämlich unter
anderem auch nervige aufnehmen
parallelen die einen mit wasser nass
machen
abwaschen geben ergebnis auf die bahn
ihre topleute ich habe heute auch wieder
kleine sachen gekauft die weggeschmissen
werden wir haben genug menschen im haus
um die chips und alles was du davon zu
verwerten also jetzt zu ina pro kilo die
kuh ist gewaschen der das werder trifft
auf jeden fall auch von der gurke
deswegen habe ich einfach mal müsst ihr
immer geben heute werden der cdu gibt
sich dieses bild ok erotische musik
[Musik]
er ist ja fast wie heute wenn euch
dieses video gefallen hat dann schreibt
ist auf jeden fall in die kommentare das
ist an sich ein video von dem noch so
viele andere machen kann allein weil mir
so viele vorschläge stoffe dieses eine
video geschickt habt die damit den
neuerdings blauen augen ist auch in der
beschreibung verlinkt check die
abboniert die und und checkt hier drüben
noch einen kleinen das video